y'a tout le monde sait ce plaisir jeudi
la compagnie de ces bois free jet
limbourg jeudi son haut parce qu'il l'a
pas d'hier
narcissique au point de dire non non
c'est pas une question d'être
narcissique
narcissique monsieur moi je dis ce but
d'acheter vidéo j'ai pas là c'est ok bon
alors aujourd'hui on est sûr résister
c'est qu'il ya un petit peu la marque
free gel l'asie alors d'en mesurer sur
minecraft sur maps toy story le nom de
la mode ailleurs c'est toy story 2 et
s'avère assez assez impressionnant
franchement je sais pas ce que tu en
penses pas mais bah rien que là le petit
dino qui faisait des indications c'est
plutôt énorme gigantesque un cmb en
passant black de nos lacs alors vas-y on
monte l'échelle alors anne on attend
avant d une petite boîte dans cette
boîte
on a des équipements voilà on a une
poitrine donc à savoir un casque on a un
lisseur aux tuniques
donc en gros c'est des petits vêtements
tissus quoi une petite c'est ça une
petite épée en bois
si je ne me trompe pas ma foi et des
torches jeu l'équipe et mon armure déjà
moi tu vois voilà alors et c'est quoi
les steaks les éclairs c'est de la
nourriture saine
ben c'est la nourriture l'accord qui le
trouvent au cc l'électricité cédée pied
on est des jouets donc d'accord ok bon
élan drôle et je connais des mecs comme
ça
d'accord donc je me trouve de tout de
touche moi je suis pour un séjour des
personnes là alors hop on a tout ça sur
nous ou [ __ ] moi c'est stylé
l'interface tu as vu il manque une cata
temps je mets ma tête aussi
tu le vois le reflet est le reflet de la
tête à la finale
c'est génial c'est un croisement génial
attends je vais juste faire un petit
retour in aux déceptions du jeu voilà
c'est fait tout est enfin prêt on est
donc équipé on a des steaks à temps
parce que moi j'ai pris que 5 steak dans
la tranche aussi font des tanches
enfin l'agent des prix 32 wen en 1064
maintenant à majorer 64,6 alors c'est
parfait
hop voilà ep steak je prends de l'estate
qui reste et on a vraiment la classe
avec cela on est vraiment on est
vraiment bogaert a pris deux épées toi
ou pas non j'ai appris qu'une mais non
merci
la présence de prendre d'engagement
d'accord voilà genevois est trop prudent
si c'est oui c'est un échec ce projet
allez on sent la merde quoi ça sert mais
j'ai un petit bouton sur dinosaures on
sait jamais j'appelais dessus ouais
attend jeune doll
ok bon allez on se casse alors on passe
par une parade échelle ballon était
apparu donc en fait dire à oui c'est
vrai qu'à rien c'est vrai oui c'est là
où on vit oui oui ces deux là on vient
d'ailleurs faut préciser que pour ceux
qui voudraient jouer sur la carte
mayorat le lien dans la description des
vidéos comme d'habitude évidemment alors
ils assurent des indications allemande
et anglaise toulouse blanche josh wise
as glauque et c'est du polonais un
battant je m'appuie sur tous les boutons
au cas où au pin up
voilà ça fait des petits textes sais pas
si tu les vois tu me fais tellement peur
tu me fais mon père quand tu dis ça j'ai
appelé sur tous les boutons à la tête et
genre de mec qui touche les boutons des
gens à temps plein et pas moyen de
monter dans la plante à grave
attends attends c'est sûr en moyens les
effets le parfois donc c'est la pop
gosse
[ __ ] comment t'as fait il sent bon le
maire après l'or et baron faut préciser
qu'on n'a pas droit cassé le cul donc
vous faut gérer les gars j'ai réussi
qu'un jouet si j'arrive hop hop ça tu
feras tu vas me regarde avec ta tête de
fourbe l'agent régnait les deux cours je
signe fort de tous les efforts qu est-ce
qu il ya qu est-ce qu il alors tu penses
que c'est le chemin qu'il fallait
prendre alors je pense que pas du tout
mais c'est drôle enfin je sais pas ou
non
merde merde ouais voilà c'est ça le
défaut alors nous on est les gros
babouins en fait on s'amuse à monter aux
arbres
d'entrée de jeu on n'est pas le nom
n'est pas de là tout de suite commencé à
la map on aime bien non au mitage effet
moyens non non mais moi non mais c'est
pas possible mais je crois qu'on est on
est des vrais cons et la paix rhdp après
on a fait un bref voilà y'a bon allez on
se casse
est-ce que c'était une grosse idée de
merde alors la plante verte europe
hop hop hop hop tu peux décrire on s'est
un peu c'est un peu y avait sur ce coup
là je peux même pas en danger donc pas
tu veux pas m'attaquer peuple alors
vas-y nouvelle boîte
alors voilà donc là le petit cochon vous
voyez sur le fond jaune c
monnaie du jeu donc ça représente 5
points un cochon il ya aussi un livre
qui explique le principe du cochon en
gros on peut s'en servir sur ce à quoi
d'ailleurs ces points je ne sais pas
mais d'ailleurs ça obligera tobin
ramasser non là d'accord donc battant
j'ai contacté je t'ordonne fois le
régime tient chaque été des pizzas
planète hockey voilà c'est ça as-tu la
loupe et tu l'a loupé il est encore là
pour ça la 2 mm entretoit le truc mais
tu le sun la scène n'a pas pris aux
regards derrière
il nous indique le chemin qu'il ya un
passage secret non ces pays là où
génération attend à la vache qu'elle va
tous se bat là-bas
normal quoi non par contre l'autre côté
du mur je crois qu'il ya une bosse un
jeu passes ton temps j'entends un gros
bruit à d'accord ok donc s'était caché
pour telle point acheter en direct tu te
masturbes alors je suis offert aux faits
a admis dans les trois cas il a été en
mode nos clips
je pense qu'en vélo casque parce qu'on y
voit rien avec voilà c'est mieux on n'y
voit rien tu trouves ouais je sais c'est
fun au début mais alors là c'est vrai
qu'à la longue c'est un petit peu
diamant comme eux
alors donc à soissons le dinosaure
chambre d'andy en fait j'ai beau c'est
quoi ce que j'ai au mec pas d'origine
watts
oui c'est vrai c'est une main c'est une
main l'arc c'est super stylé mec c'est
genre une main et combat du truc ouais
bah ouais je vous parle donc pas grand
chose d'ici mai
puis la rend pas est ce que je suis en
vidéo c'est pour ça là je peux pas
acheter
bonzi brésil fait un peu moins fort bon
alors c'est bon c'est pas enfin non
tranquille tranquille où allons nous
donc la bahia il avait plein de monstres
affligé demon's souls est libre c'est ça
en fait à mon avis ah oui et c'est de là
que vient la légende donc en fait faut
qu'on aille devant la chambre dans dix
bars d'ailleurs on y est je crois j'ai
un droit commun this and jump le
musicien a sauté sur le bureau le bureau
le bureau il est là bas des allées
voyage à l'île aux orres la highway
d'accord donc en fait les gens vous ou
qui ne savent pas on doit toujours
rejoindre l'ue dinosaures sarah meier
c'est un petit peu le principe de la
vider du de la map et redonne ce soit
mon cher ce sont mon cher vous attends
je fais gaffe hier à mons la battue va
peut-être faire attaquer ça va laisser
tranquille et les lois non moi j'entre
dans cette petite maison en vue de leur
tête que tu as vu que la tête c'est des
points les points leur tête c'est des
points regarde merde voilà genre ah non
en fait c'est évidemment je sais pas de
quelle superbe
par contre il ya un creepers web on va
chez ouais on va le laisser tranquille
ennuis je viens là dedans bien je suis
là je suis là je suis là hier soir à
west point le rend très beau temps mais
bon il peut être pas au cul
alors en ce moment mais apparemment on
peut monter temps je montais oui mais je
comprends pas sûr quand on est carré je
sais pas peut-être une table basse
possible en tout cas le bureau c'est par
là elle va jeter suis non d'accord donc
quelqu'un qui soit pas réussir à sauter
c'est moi par contre j'ai paul pietsch
la remarque je ne te permets pas gd
chose
vainqueur alors ça me met ça m'étonne de
toile voilà parfait parfait bien sûr que
j'allais courir alors hop hop on est
dans le bureau là bas un point lors via
un pont à gauche on va éclairer avec nrj
chalet il fallait monter il fallait
annonce tu là mais non là il est les
échecs tu l'as lu wei d'ailleurs bien
classés bon ben alors on à moi j'ai deux
points j'ai mis en vedette du point ça
fait pas penser à ceux à ce jeu là sur
ces plus c'est sur playstation
playstation 2 un jeu toy story si j'ai
réussi j'ai aussi bassil bref ainsi que
tu as des piles et des éclairs c'est le
même principe faut ramasser tout ça bah
en fait je me demande même ce n'est pas
les maps la même map qui leur produit
est bon je me souviens pas du tout donc
aussi bien mon avis c'est pas mal
inspiré parce que le landau par exemple
enfin ceux où est le berceau va plutôt 5
à penser à quelque chose
samedi un truc aussi en tout cas c'est
super drôle ça fait un peut aussi penser
aux mapera dans counter strike the past
ya déjà joué à valence 5e genre deux
rate doha est en fait le principe c'est
que tu es à la taille d'un rat dans une
chambre ou dans une pièce en fait c'est
exactement comme ça c'est super marrant
alors ça les bonnes classes et gênantes
là bas je sais pas permis à jean augé
répulsion bouton up
qu'est-ce qu'on a là dedans on a le
livre vas-y vas-y premières quêtes temps
je le mets des villes où moi je le
prends finale ukm finalement tu es tu
arrivé combien de temps j'étais attendu
alors écoute moins attentivement dans
cette chambre il
il y à des quêtes que tu vas devoir
compléter pour aller à la chambre
suivante situant loupé une tu peux
perdre
bon ok donc your first au ski ce go to
donc votre première tâche est d'aller
comment tourner la page avec la petite
flèche en bas à droite et d'aller tous
du crib in fine first start of the key
je sais pas c'est quoi tous de kribi
alors je viens voir parce que pour le
coup plus de crise et trouver la
première partie de la clé ici vous
trouverez la quête suivante aussi c'est
parti oh et une autre chose si vous
voulez de touche
si vous voulez changer le temps du matin
la zone o'mine ait bien d'accord non il
disait si vous voulez mettre leur parler
l'anglais avec ceux ci vous si vous
voulez mettre leur du matin appuyer sur
le bouton présente ainsi qu on trouvait
des sticks hull donc c'est juste à
l'heure alors qu'ils nous ont étouffés
belle au niveau du cou donc c'est l'audi
du bébé et regarde par la fenêtre show
qu'on a un petit côté avec les nuages la
nd soleil c'est joli les choux gras
c'est mignon oui c'est pas toi qui avais
un map pack over puissant avec le soleil
c'est effet battlefield un petit peu
c'est tellement beau ça ça peut rendre à
taïwan check point que là je te propose
depuis le dessus
ouais je j'accepte la proposition avec
plaisir
alors on envoie ravi où est donc celui
de bébé eh bien il est là alors par
contre j'ai vu une indication ouais
c'est un arbre à fait moi ça n'a aucun
pouvoir là j'avoue tout et c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont bien précisé qu'on doit pas
péter un seul blog télé gauvin et il ya
toujours des petits chemins et tu parles
mastercard alors c'est gratuit alors ils
disent donc jump use les deux les le à
la veille il ya des die d'ailleurs là
comme un albédo chaude et bien prenons
il a été bon j'ai pris la laideur j'ai
pris là leader et c'est toi le leader
alors tu avances
fallait il n'y a pas une échelle alors à
temps hier on était tombé là bas quand
tu remontes eh bien eh bien eh bien eh
bien eh bien par ici
ajouter les participants et je te bras
qu'avec un point
ok je te braque avec un point et c'est
quoi ton pseudo est super compliqué à
écrire cmr squeeze genre comme ça alors
comme ça parfait nous aider c'est
reparti direction bah oui c'est juste là
en fait michael c'est aux attendes haut
up annuel incluant ckoi à temps à
ramasser son caca brille on regarde bien
voir en fait tu peux le faire
regarde tatavel animations ou pas oui
bah ça me fait sortir
voilà c'est très drôle à aa
on a un deuxième cadeau tu sais quoi
c'est un livre au il avait mangé de
chasse bizarre ces cochons d'accord ok
en fait tu peux faire sortir toutes
sortes de choses de son anus quoi genre
de l'aris l'aune des diamants mais par
contre j'ai eu un truc de redstone par
contre alors bien jouer vous l'avez fait
vous avez trouvé la première partie de
lacs et de la deûle a claqué de la kek
et votre second objectif est d'aller
dans le lit dans 10 de trouver la
deuxième partie de la clé je suis sûr
que si on arrive à tous pelles et celle
sur son nez il ya un point tout là haut
et ne tiraient pas autant dire que non
j'y arrive pas non je crois que celle ci
atteindra beaucoup en fait non on peut
pas à moins que non on peut pas alors
mais on peut pas le choix on à la
pratique laqué deuxième mission sénat où
tu m'as dit en le disant dit alors le
leader oui et non vous êtes à devenir
chaufferie chi ou je te sens tu sais un
peu fragile à paris quand j'en vois tous
grillés à yes alors c'est bien de vous
pouvez compter le nombre de jeux de mots
cas dans cette vidéo absolument
incroyable enfin ils sont partagés le
tapis si génial ça ouais pas mal
j'aime bien aussi l'effet de parquer sur
le sol un tueur s il ya des espèces
règnera oui des rires dans la salle rez
ouais j'avais même pas qu'elle est c'est
pas mal j'avoue comment ré dans son lit
là c'est super au sens où les russes on
lit ça oui [ __ ]
est-ce que y'a pas moyen d'y aller par
en dessous non peut-être qu'il faut
aller sur le truc noir pour sauter
regarde là haut j'ai l'impression tu
crois ou alors la table basse là bas
mais elle a l'air un petit peu pour
tableau tableau passe alors ouais et
cela est une garde bien la barrière
l'horloge on parle de la guerre des
alliés sur une cheminée un petit chemin
après soir il ya un petit lien que ces
choix aussi des arts le bonhomme la
regarde bailly nous dit juste que il
nous indique il estimé je trouve je sais
pas je sais pas ce que c'est comme moi
non plus la star est ce qu'on peut
grimper
c'est une peluche une peluche simplement
là ou alors on était celle qui ne mènent
à rien de faire le jem est attentatoire
à temps elle est un peu grand là on peut
là a bien joué d'accord on s'était
montés sur l'échelle pour sauter sur le
tri sol sur l'échelle tu prends que
l'élan voilà parfait parfait et on va
aller là ensuite il ya une autre échelle
là bas je pense que tu la vois pas je
pense que ces salons via une échelle là
bas oh oui oh oui
hop on monte on est on est on y est donc
c'est pas mal plateforme vrai mais c'est
sympa que si c'est ça fait un petit
casse-tête bon de kadhafi -gel avec toi
tu un petit panda joker donc c'est moins
juste plaisir comme ça alors on va aller
j'ai cru qu'avoir trucs écrits n'est pas
du tout pas du tout alors attends je
monte chez les toits donc tu me chie
dessus aussi donc toi tu es seul tu as
syndrome du cochon en fait concrètement
mais en même temps tu es d'accord d'un
point voilà donc c'est bien ce que ce
que je souhaite c'est sur ce bonne
augure
attention ne rate pas tu auras pas non
c'est bon ça sinon on était foutu alors
que la pression sinon c'est pas drôle
je pense qu'au fond il ya un point là de
bonne foi même [ __ ] mais j'ai
tellement hâte qu'on puisse dépenser nos
points lâchés l'été je suis vachement
pris par la map en tout cas je sais pas
toi
mais alors c'est au stand navire que je
suis vachement pris la parole à 160 au
matin attendez moi j'avais un point chez
arte mais attends mais faut passer par
les petits trucs bleus ouais tu t'es
chier oui au plus tard je suis mort
c'est vrai je l'espère je l'espère parce
que moi si je meurs
[ __ ] mais phrygien mais tu
t'arrive-t-il ou je ne sais pas je ne
sais pas je ne suis pas moi-même j'ai
l'impression abcès bien sûr qu'il faut
pas sauter directement de la bouche font
sur le truc blanc là bas résille saute
sur lui d'accord alors quand je me tais
bfre histoire merci parfait alors on est
sur le lit joli mais franchement c'était
vraiment que c'est vraiment ça qui va
être tué on est sur le lit c'est joli
pour une politique non mais je sais pas
mais pour avoir regardé des toy story
donc de pixar d'ailleurs peu pressés des
studios pixar ya pas longtemps je trouve
que ses membres ressemblent angoisses
ses baladeurs les colorer ses pas il ya
une boîte de gino ya une grosse
différence entre le toy story 1
vas-y je te laisse prendre les points et
ses hommes hop et la red stone j'en ai
aussi un chai pas à quoi ça va servir
mais ça va forcément servir battle the
tourist est quand même un des pulsars
les pluies dont le principe était
vraiment extra fan tu vois des coûts des
jouets qui parle c'est un petit peu un
délire de fons des comme d'un peu
partout les pixar mais ça ça vole bon
alors alors bravo vous l'avez fait vous
avez trouvé deuxième partie de là qu'est
maintenant vous pouvez aller sur la
commode cabinet ouest wroclaw blanc
ouais c'est ça avec le globe sur lui
mais attention il ya des trucs dangereux
dedans j'espère que vous avez une épée
d'accord donc au sahara star quoi ça va
ça va ça va swinguer hugues duboscq 2e
séparés en plus haut bien joué ouais
c'est ça on me dit souvent bien joué
comme ça quand j'ai réussi un saut ce
qui est assez incroyable et on dit aussi
souvent mal joué ça commence par un saut
est toujours là haut est inquiète j'ai
réussi voilà
canac shaw most d'accord j'y viens pique
nique génial je suis arrivée là haut
puis j'entends friggit elle dure t la
merde c'est bref tu es bien sûr d'être
un numéro sans tomber ça m'étonne de
noël je te promets que j'étais arrivé au
la preuve en vidéo
voilà vous l'avez vu sous vos yeux euh
ah merci tu m'as tp chavez et je te
laisse le faire parce que moi je fais
une grosse bataille mais attendez bond
incroyable plus tard brawn gp mois après
une échelle en bas il enchaîne pour les
losers va pas aller bien loin dans cette
scène et si mais si mais si on est très
très fort alors qu'arnaud donc ben oui
mes chers
ouais non mais tu peux pas y accéder
c'est un troll tue même si tu sautes tu
peux y accéder au moins aux yeux et
poids j'attaque le point avec mon steak
et la demande à quoi on a six mois j'ai
eu istèque perso tu as quoi tout autant
de journées j'en ai je vois si prompt à
s'en prendre non il ya bien sûr
comprendre pourquoi on a eu deux filles
molle encore je sais pas d'ailleurs
c'est plutôt jusqu'à quatre cochons on
nous aurait des journaux mais c'est
blake griffin aujourd'hui les vagues
hydro du monde
alors bon allez donc comment comment
commence pas comme jeanne faire déjà de
base
l'agent plus bas explorant basij
exploits de mon côté et si j'explorais
aussi de ton côté
j'ai failli tomber non il ya forcément
un truc à faire depuis ici on se
réveille toi tu regardes là-bas en bas
là on peut monter un petit peu sur le
blanc là bas il ya une échelle encore
gars en face là il ya une échelle
citoyenne il ya plein de monstres ya
plein d'autres
on va monter sur le gland l'échelle
cerader sont en fait sa beauté genre de
mec qui monte sur le blanc quoi c'est à
temps je m'étais faite aux la petite
voix de la chine
je prends la jouer là dessus
un hôpital c'est un petit peu blanc tout
ça on est on est on est dix ans on est
oui on est plutôt tokyo friands tout ça
alors je te suis je te suis je job dans
un labyrinthe en ligne droite je mets
des landes pour qu'on retrouve notre
choix c'est le mec qui met pas des
vaches r ils mettent des lampes roses ou
le sac en toile qui coûte 1000 euros là
ok on est dans le tiroir posé sur un
problème n ya pas aussi par la peur la
faim j'entendais louis darré dire
j'entends les années les zombies faut
les top shot à les violer - l'autre côté
du mur c'est là pour te protéger
d'accord j'ai hâte et l'autre côté et
bien évidemment je suis pas bien joué de
sa part
heureusement qu'on peut souhaiter qu'ils
lanceraient dans la merde oui c'est un
peu des clercs ses bars ou sommet éclair
au chocolat jeu de mot de passe que
j'oublie toujours la touche mot [ __ ]
d'inventaire soit déjà
[ __ ] mais je la trouve plus à la voile
à eux que je m'acharne est clair tu a
sauté sur l'échelle toi ouais j'ai sauté
sur un chef d'état mais tout comme ça
sur les sur les choses
un petit loyer maka qui dans la tête tu
vois bien moins quatre cas qui continue
tout droit tout droit et je tue mais
attention l'ennemi
voilà vous plaît bien je pense qu'il
peut être à jamais en fait qu'ai je me
suis battu pour toi pôv stark je te
laisse te prendre qu'est ce que ça veut
dire c'est parti bobst art
ouais c'est le nom du livre au dessus du
départ alors troisième partie de la clé
mais attends mais quand ces trucs à la
red stone age et de la fin de la partie
de là que l'art est d'accord majoré g3
c'est bon maintenant c'est parti pour
trouver la dernière partie mais je
ferais quoi d'accord c'est parti pour
trouver la dernière partie peu avec
préjugés ou fait des jeux de mots
pourris de plus dû me dire qu'est ce
qu'un dresseurs pokémon c'est ça c'est
pas un truc et ça même agresseur c'est
cette faille c'est incroyable ces
agresseurs c'est une commode
voilà une commode d'accord c'est à dire
que free gel et à son gros iphone juste
à côté
absolument pas il scanne l'écran
carrément deuxième samsung c'est pareil
grosso modo ya pas de guerre mais pas
les couilles alors on a un arbre à point
nommé roi fois encore globe à points à
les problèmes points attends je perds
mais je me caresse faire le tour voir
dans ses moyens
moi je suis moi j'suis le gros connards
qui fait rien qu'à a fait ça j'ai un
acte anodin
à tanger des centaines de noms mais la
réunion était gentil il fait jour à deux
jours les araignées sont gentilles à la
jsk on araignée mutante elle te bouffer
d'accord ok donc c'est un jeu de pervers
quoi genre la nuitée morts en fait ça un
bon très bien alors je crois qu'on a
tous on a plein de points mais qu à quoi
vont servir les points savez je ne sais
pas c'est tout simplement à la fin du
jeu pour voir ton score quoi a
checkpoint merde non non on n'a plus
mature c'est un put pas cet avis non
mais ça m'a amené en bas il avait un
bouton il a fait j'appuie sur le bouton
alors qu'ici à plein temps d'écrire un
petit bouton
alors là il ya un levier j'ai pas
répudier dessus donc je vais te laisser
le faire ça va sortir un truc du cul du
cochon c'est sûr grandeur distance phare
battant même tu peux tu pars du mouton
l'asie appuyé sur ses fesses appuyez sur
la cause d'une tour à temps j'arrive au
oui j'en avais tu as il avait bien
manger avant lui à vaches
alors regardez
j'ai on se prend déjà de battre enfin 11
11 et 12 à 12 j'ai eu un livre qui
s'appelle guette reward au kate and
twitter machinery and get your world
gold t.abx a pas de poste et ericsson
ici tient ici 1 1 par cube d'accord
alors attends je te le fais attendez
toujours je galère un petit pas trouvé
cette [ __ ] de toucher à la partie e up
et nous l'expression rosé
voilà je vais sonneurs d'appuyer au oui
ça a ouvert un truc non oui ça va venir
ici c'est génial magnifique ça c'est
super vous avez complété la poire on a
des meilleures armes des mines à un arc
des flèches les petits traits rouges
chez des flèches aux attentes j'en
prends la dea des trucs en faire
maintenant c'est génial ouais
hier tu penses que l'interface du casque
il a changé un petit peu ou pas non je
pense que c'est la même
c'est ne s'est trouvé en fait j'avais il
ya moyen un regard derrière on va buzz
et woody
en attendant bien attends je vais
regarder je m'équipe juge prend des
appels et une senteurs voudra tu me
demandes n'ya pas de soucis moi je suis
en route pour l'instant ça me rappelle
en effet un fournisseur d'appareils
sortes de pommes
voilà c'est ça alors j'ai créé une pomme
à pied mais elle est bien tout cas elle
serait encore mieux et surtout que bon
ayew n'ont par contre pas d'accord je
proteste je te préviens direct thomas
struth genre de mec cache d'ailleurs je
vois alors est ce que tu vois assez loin
pour voir le dessin derrière attend le
dessin attend deux secondes parce que il
faut que j'aie toujours en train de
mettre son armure oui et puis s'il est
loin que ça et j'ai pas l'armure d'iron
man qui se font en deux minutes
howie génial pas mal hein tu as tu
aurais dû reprendre le ski du cowboy âge
tendre et jetant oui parce que moi pour
info les gens j'ai le skin deux baisses
des fleurs c'est pour que la vidéo fait
le buzz c'est ça alors là
oui un point d'eau oui alors à temps
parce que ça ça va être au madhya macaci
au revoir je vais jouer
[ __ ] j'ai tout perdu mais qu annoncé
bande annonce attends je vais tomber sur
toi fais pas de vitesse pas de betty à
tanger vient de lui plonger entente ou
là à moi je dis je retente j'avais même
pas tenté et graves mais qui me vole ma
phrase je retente te dirais tu na loba
put victoire je suis je suis je suis bon
bah mais je te félicite pas bah oui
aujourd'hui j'étais plutôt nul mais ne
t'inquiète pas je suis parmi nous a
désormais alors donc on monte encore ces
petits trucs rouge t'as j'adore cette
map doit s'échanger sur une horloge
ça fait vraiment prendre goût à
minecraft tu vois ce jour n'est menacée
valent elles sont vraiment bien fait et
tu vois même par l'appel on dirait que
on dire qu'il ya un quartier dehors et
tout je sais pas si tu attends refait
enfin c'est quoi baj par regarder par
dessus et ce qu'ils n'ont rien mais
quand tu et à toi oui oui on dirait
qu'il ya un trottoir et ou par la
fenêtre
ouais ça c'est balasy faut continuer
donc de sauter je suis tombé
[ __ ] t'es fait moins vite sur tp toi
vite sur moi ok il n'était pas sur toi
c'est pas grave tu vois le camp alors
que les soldats
d'accord c'est pas grave d'ailleurs la
quête me disait d'aller goût assumé de
questions toi qui avais le livre de la
casbah elle nous disait pas d'aller mais
je pense que là on était sur un chemin
quoi donc on sera rivé sur l'étagère et
il ya quelque chose qui vous aurait dit
non sur rolland non c'était les panneaux
qui nous avait dit qu'on a complété la
première requête et qu'on devait aller
autre part mais j'ai déjà oublié où
c'était baala on était en train de faire
dans l'équipe par friggit mais non on
était en hausse c'était fini en fait on
a fini cette semaine
d'accord ok ouais on était derrière
l'attaqué attention parce que oui
donc j'essaie tôt à la fin du siècle
regardons était en fait on était sur
l'horloge l'avons donc c'était un cul de
sac
ok bah ouais et battant on va descendre
les alors de serre note voir aussi quand
tu compte couplé à la coupe et la vidéo
parce que la carte a l'air assez grand
donc je pense que ce sera sur eux
oui alors atteignent va bientôt mettre
fin la vidéo et on met fin à une vidéo
sur ce premier niveau incroyable auprès
des deux
deux mois et voilà le frij elle donc à
la pression en puissions j'attends une
[ __ ] donc à bientôt pour le deuxième
épisode toujours plus d'un retour dans
toy story et phrase de fin vers l'infini
et au delà